nouveau numéro de notre rendez vous
consacré la présidentielle en france
france 2022 l'heure du choix comme
chaque soir avec h rennes verdien
bonsoir allergies -5 avant le second
tour oui pas de meeting pas de
déplacement aujourd'hui pour les deux
finalistes du second tour à la veille du
débat de mercredi soir point d'orgue de
cette campagne de l'entre-deux-tours un
moment clé qui peut faire basculer une
élection alors le président sortant s'y
préparent et surtout la candidate du
rassemblement national qui avait on s'en
rappellera t l'exercice de son propre
aveu en 2010 est tout de même fait
diffuser aujourd'hui une vidéo dans
laquelle elle met en scène son duel avec
emmanuel macron et leurs visions
antinomique de l'avenir de la france le
récap politique est signée florent
roudaut et lucile la toux
c'est l'histoire d'un débat à n'en pas
douter le point culminant de cette
campagne sur le plateau l'heure est aux
ultimes préparatifs
à la veille de croiser le fer les deux
finalistes se prépare en coulisses et
laisse la lumière des plateaux alors
lieutenant
côté rn sébastien chenu et confiant
marine le pen a appris de ses erreurs
commises il ya cinq ans elle est prête
un axe stratégique qui je crois a été
choisie qui n'avait pas été le bon prix
nobel souhaitait démontrer montré qu'ils
étaient menés macron de démasquer alors
qu'en fait on attendait d'elle plutôt
qu'elle montre qu' elle était elle-même
et ses propres erreurs du passé
exactement ce qu'on attend d'un débat
présidentiel de vision de la société de
projet savoir en nous emmène et comment
nous y emmène dans le camp macron on a
désormais un bilan à défendre et une
adversaire bien plus coriace qu'en 2017
a disqualifié la stratégie depuis
plusieurs jours martelé aux français le
danger que représente marine le pen et
l'extrême droite le premier ministre
jean castex y va de sa petite histoire
la voit apparaître avec ses charrier
pour se rendre aimable et sympathique ça
me rappelle une femme qui s'appelle le
chat la belette petit lapin ce chat il
est tout doux tout gentil et quand ce
pauvre petit lapin et cette pauvre bête
arrive jusqu'à dix usines et rock et les
manges bon ben c'est ça derrière marine
il toujours le panis faut quand même
leur rappeler rappeler aussi que marine
le pen souhaite arrêter la coopération
en matière d'industrie de l'armement
avec berlin deuxième couche passer par
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
entend une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle vous dire que dans le
fond cette amitié franco allemande moi
je veux la remettre en question elle ne
remet pas simplement question cette
amitié elle remet en question à méritage
elle remet en question ce qui est
désormais une part de l'identité
nationale française c'est tout
simplement une folie voilà c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve demain
à cinq jours du second tour le
traditionnel coup d'oeil aux sondages
oui selon notre partenaire ipsos sopra
steria l'écart se creuse légèrement
entre les deux finalistes le président
sortant est crédité de 56 et demi pour
cent des voix en progression donc d'un
demi point et c'est une baisse d'un demi
point en revanche pour la candidate du
rassemblement national marine le pen
désormais crédité de 43 et demi pourcent
quant au taux de participation il serait
de 71 % en baisse donc de 1 point par
rapport à hier toujours selon elle notre
partenaire ipsos sopra et steria elle
serait l'une des grandes inconnues à ce
stade c'est vers qui vont se tourner et
les français qui ont voté pour jean luc
mélenchon au premier tour oui selon
ipsos il serait 39% à voter pour
emmanuel macron contre 16 pour marine le
pen 45% des personnes interrogées ne
s'exprimant pas le leader de la france
insoumise lui appelle toujours à ne pas
voter marine le pen sans appeler à voter
pour emmanuel macron ils demandent en
tout cas aux français surtout de lui
donner une majorité
lors du troisième tour c'est à dire aux
législatives on va l'écouter moi je ne
veux pas que madame le pen prennent le
pays et je ne veux pas que monsieur
macron garde le pouvoir et je dois
résoudre cette contradiction on est
jeune la rezzouk d'une manière en disant
il ya un troisième tour je serai donc le
premier ministre pas par la faveur ou la
grâce pardon mais c'est moins pire jeu
monsieur macron une madame le pen mais
parce que les français leur ont voulu
après les étudiants de sciences po de la
sorbonne c'est au tour des lycéens
parisiens de se mobiliser pour faire
entendre leur voix dans cet entre deux
tours oui plusieurs lits les parisiens
ont été bloqués aujourd'hui parmi
lesquels les célèbres louis laurent ou
encore henri iv dans le 5e
arrondissement de paris les lycée
lavoisier ou encore fénelon objectif de
ces élèves alerter sur le danger que
représente selon le l'extrême droite et
alerter aussi sur les questions
écologiques et sociales qu'ils estiment
négligé dans cette campagne
présidentielle ces actions se sont
déroulées sans violence et dans une
ambiance plutôt bon enfant les
directions maintenant les hauts-de-seine
l'une des régions à léo de france l'une
des régions où marine le pen est arrivé
en tête au premier tour 1 c'est pas la
même chose oui c'est la bac emmanuel
macron s'était rendu à la semaine
dernière pour tenter de convaincre et ce
n'est pas chose facile dans la
population semble acquise à la candidate
du rassemblement national nos reporters
julie d'une golf est clair pas qu'alain
sont allés dans la commune d'abscon
voyez le reportage
nous sommes sur les terres électorales
de marine le pen bonjour madame un
discours dans cette ville de 4000
habitants des hauts de france marine le
pen a frôlé les 50 % dès le premier
avion aux questions qu'elles baissent
c'est free cité elles baissent le gaz lb
ce ton donc c'est plus intéressant moi
quand vous voyez ma voiture je mets 20
euros par jour
que c'est plus possible possible on est
en train de prouver de même pour nos
enfants plus tard en fait moi je vois là
mon fils avait un talent et un travail
sa logique là lurons n'est maintenant
pas tout si
c'est la france oubliée des manuels
macron qui s'intéressent pas forcément
là la politique est qui qui s'y
intéressent qu on va qu'on va aller
chercher finalement à bâle à chaque fois
qu puisque dans un sens comme dans
l'autre l'élection sera très serrée dans
cette ville ouvrière les fermetures
d'usinés ont fait basculer près d'un
tiers de la population dans le chômage
alors ses habitants veulent croire à la
hausse du pouvoir d'achat
promise par marine le pen on est gamin
trop
vous avez débuté dimanche a noté
marie le pen
tout reconfigurer
sociaux mis pour cause et c'est une
journée
compliquée en gasoil
macron c'est
sur ces territoires largement favorables
à marine le pen l'abstention est plus
élevé que la moyenne nationale abce
coûts par exemple ce sont 37 % des
électeurs qui ne sont pas allés voter au
premier tour c'est soutien de marine le
pen le sable il faudra convaincre
jusqu'à la dernière minute pour tenter
de faire mentir les sondages on va
revenir à présent sur l'une des
thématiques majeures de cette campagne
il s'agit bien sûr du pouvoir d'achat
oui en mars dernier marine le pen était
interrogé sur la façon dont elle
comptait s'y prendre pour réaliser sa
promesse de rendre de l'argent aux
français sa mesure phare baisser la tva
de 20 à 5 et demi pour cent sur le gaz
le fioul l'électricité et les carburants
écoutait la ct chez nos confrères de
france je suis désolé mais baisser la
tva c'est voter non à d'accord donc
c'est pas compliqué du tout combien à
baisser la tva de 20% à 5 5 sur
l'intégralité de l'énergie c'est à dire
le gaz l'électricité le fioul et le
carburant c'est rendre 12 milliards
d'euros immédiatement aux français ce
avec là dessus les textes européens ne
le permettent pas aujourd'hui ce sont
des biens de première nécessité et à
partir du moment où on considère que ce
sont des biens de première nécessité
comme d'autres biens de première
nécessité en france on arrive à 5,5 de
tva et on en parle ce sens avec maya
anaïs iata guen bonsoir maya est ce que
cette mesure proposée par marine le pen
est faisable et bien pas vraiment parce
que autant pour la fourniture de gaz
naturel d'électricité et de chauffage
urbain c'est envisageable en effet
autant pour les carburants c'est
carrément non il faut le dire parce
qu'en france il y à un taux normal de
tva qui est de 20 % et un taux réduit de
5% la liste exacte des biens qui peuvent
bénéficier de ce taux de 5% est défini
dans un cadre européen
cette liste elle a été rallongée
récemment mais dedans il n'y a toujours
pas les carburants alors marine le pen
dit qu'elle peut négocier qu'elle peut
ajouter les carpes loire les carburants
dans cette liste mais en fait c'est
peine perdue parce qu'il faudrait
convaincre tous les états membres de
renoncer à leurs engagements climatiques
qu'ils ont signés dans le cadre du pacte
vert européen pour réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre est-ce que
marine le pen peut quand même passer en
force alors bien sûr au risque de
s'attirer les foudres de la commission
européenne elle peut essayer un et
risquer une action en manquement pour
non respect du droit européen passer en
force et un pays qu'il a fait c'est la
pologne pour essayer de répondre à une
inflation galopante aujourd'hui de 11 %
c'est la pire depuis les années 2000 les
prêts d'énergie ont explosé et donc la
pologne a décidé de baisser la tva sur
les carburants à 8% à 0 % sur le gaz
naturel c'est ils l'ont fait sans
demander l'avis l europe 1 alors que
c'est donc on ferme ou non conforme au
droit européen c'est exactement ce que
propose marine le pen la commission nous
a confirmé que elle suivait la situation
polonaise de très près mais qu'elle
était en contact avec arceau vie mais
actuellement on ne voit aucune sanction
en vue il faut noter que marine le pen
propose une baisse définitive de la tv
alors que pour la pologne c'est encore
provisoire coût total prévu pour
l'instant 7 milliards d'euros pour
l'état et cela permettrait aux polonais
d'économiser 5,4 milliards alors quel a
été l'effet en pologne eh bien on a un
petit spot du gouvernement à vous
montrer une famille heureuse qui peut
enfin faire le plein à lui mais toutes
les lumières tous les appareils
électroménagers est même remonté le
chauffage grâce au bouclier du
gouvernement ça c'est l'image de rêve
que vous montrez le parti nationaliste
et conservateur au pouvoir mais en
réalité les faits n'a pas été aussi
puissants caisse compte et je vous
propose d'écouter le docteur jakobowski
pardon experts du marché des carburants
le jour où la tva a baissé le prix du
diesel et du gasoil a baissé d'environ
10%
sept visibles dans toutes les stations
service de pologne
mais la mesure a eu lieu à un moment où
le prix des carburants grimpait sur les
marchés en très peu de temps les prix
sont repartis à la hausse
alors des effets limités un qui en plus
coûterait cher à l'état vous avez
entendu dans le sonore que vous avez
joué marine le pen dire on va rendre 12
milliards d'euros au français en fait
c'est le coût pour l'état ça veut dire
que l'état ne va pas récupérer 12
milliards d'euros de recettes fiscales
c'est donc le coût pour l'état et selon
la fondation terra nova le gain pour les
consommateurs c'est 28 euros par mois et
par ménage et ça c'est à une condition
c'est si les fournisseurs de carburants
vont répercuter cette baisse de tva dans
les prix rien ne les oblige à le faire
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec la baisse
de la tva sur la restauration
on est passé de 19,6 à 5,5 les
restaurateurs ils ont augmenté leurs
bénéfices mais pour le consommateur
c'était une mauvaise opération au final
le prix est dans l'assiette c'est que
monde pour cent merci beaucoup maya pour
ce décryptage sur cette proposition de
marine le pen pour le pouvoir d'achat
des français je le rappelle vos
reportages sur la campagne
présidentielle sont à retrouver sur
notre site internet france 24 points
comme enfin il ya un point commun en
commun en tout cas entre les deux
finalistes du second tour emmanuel
macron et marine le pen c'était le cas
d'ailleurs de la plupart des candidats à
la présidentielle ils se disputent
l'héritage du général de gaulle oui et
on prend tout de suite la direction du
fief du général colombey les deux
églises dans la haute-marne où la
répartition des voix était plutôt
étonnante au premier tour emmanuel
macron et marine le pen ont recueilli
chacun 69 voix un résultat qui a surpris
d'anciens proches du général reportage
de nos confrères de france
c'est un territoire à l'héritage
politique très symbolique
colombey-les-deux-églises où plus de 50
ans après sa mort plane toujours l'ombre
du général de gaulle alors mais bien
c'est un peu un pub l'émission
des croix de lorraine un petit peu
partout donc on sent que c'est la
référence ultime c'est difficile mais on
va pas lâcher on est motivés à fond une
semaine de campagne pleine d'enjeux
bonjour après des résultats inédits dans
le village du général alors sont arrivés
en tête monsieur emmanuel macron avec 69
voix et et madame marine le pen avec 69
voix ex-aequo une première c'est une
première tout à fait l'extrême droite en
tête ex-aequo le party les républicains
à 10% de mémoire de gaullistes on
n'avait jamais vu ça
j'en reviens porte générale étudieraient
les français sans mes mots
gérard natale y est yves consignes ont
porté le cercueil du général de gaulle
ils ne peuvent pas croire que le
rassemblement national historiquement
antigaulliste obtiennent tant de voix
aujourd'hui je suis malade comme liv il
en est malade
quand on vend
son père son père donc ça pas changé non
emmanuel macron meilleur choix au second
tour pour les gaullistes pas selon cette
représentante du rassemblement national
elle appelle à se concentrer sur le
programme actuel de marine le pen sur
l'échiquier politique aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national a beaucoup de
points de convergence avec les idées du
du
du général de gaulle bien entendu le
respect la nation la liberté la
dépendance dans les nouveaux quartiers
de colombes et de nombreux habitants se
disent prêts à écouter les arguments du
rassemblement national en particulier
chez les jeunes
nous les jeunes ça nous a pas choqué je
pense que les anciens vous à eux
mêmes le général il s'est retourné dans
l'attende mais mises à part les morial
les touristes c'est tout ce que tout le
côté convoque au fil des élections
l'héritage du général s'estompe
colombey-les-deux-églises redevient un
village comme les autres
voilà c'est tout pour ce soir claire on
se retrouve demain pour une édition
spéciale à partir de 20h15 heure de
paris consacré donc au débat crucial de
l'entre-deux tour entre marine le pen et
emmanuel macron à demain donc on peut
retrouver en attendant votre émission
sur nos réseaux sociaux et sur le site
internet de france 24
www.francebillet.com rester avec nous un
nouveau journal donc quelques instants
paris direct continue
[Musique]